so they can't show off their stuff and I
think the good thing for managerov is he
doesn't have to change his normal style
in this matchup uh he can just play his
normal chest because that leads to uh
chaos anyway and in a must-win situation
or almost must win at this point
um yeah why not just stick to your
normal openings and Magnus chooses the
slav defense the slav defense has scored
very badly actually throughout the tour
that's one thing we've noticed looking
at the statistics
and um okay just playing the triangle oh
yeah and uh Shaq actually not playing
his beloved G3 move he likes the
fianchetto the bishop and instead we
have something very mainstream and uh
it's a very solid position that black
has this is a difficult knot to crack
I've been uh studying this for a long
time and I don't find it Advantage for
white at all Magnus looks a bit confused
he's kind of looking around he's like
frowning slightly what is going on but I
think that's just because White's bishop
move is not the most common normally
White's Bishop if it wants to move moves
two squares or the White Queen shuffles
across one square yeah having said that
it's a very trendy line and it was
recently recommended by Sam shankland in
his opening repertoire course and the
whole idea is that if black were to
capture the pawn on C4 white is not
obliged to take it with a bishop you can
take the time out to make some other
moves yeah so I mean as Sam Franklin's
recommended it then all of the top
players will have taken out he's
renowned as an opening expert
so okay it's the first to have surprised
Magnus Carlsen that's a big gain that's
again a positive of the white pieces in
Chess at all levels but especially at
the top level uh where the surprise
factor is so vital the top players
they're so good they often neutralize
each other cancel each other out unless
you can cause a big surprise in the
opening and looks like Magnus is the
first to think I'm expecting Black start
Square Bishop to move black to try and
Castle as quickly as possible but
obviously very flexible lots of tempting
options at this point
and
Groff yeah I think the one thing he
needs to change and improve on the last
game is his clock usage that was his
real downfall the position was tough in
the last game
it was really hard to navigate but yeah
if you have one minute left
story of my life when you have one
minute left on the clock Things Fall
Apart on the board especially against
the top players who will uh they're
sharks who will Target you they'll smell
that blood and water I I would like to
say that happens to most people except
my co-host David who actually plays
fantastic chess with seconds left on the
clock I'm getting older it's harder a
little birdie told me that in the
Norwegian League you left it with one
second on the clock yes yeah that's a
good story of my life
riding on the edge and Magnus actually
reacting in a slightly unconventional
way I mean it's slightly unconventional
because normally black is actually
developing the dark Square Bishop but
this is uh all normal as long as the
dark Square Bishop actually develops two
squares forward
and uh manager of playing some very
trendy ideas here moving the a pawn
forward that's partly aimed at clamping
down so black can't push any pawns on
that Left Flank but also if given the
time there is the opportunity maybe to
push the white a pawn even further there
is a clear Target black to light squared
Bishop if that white apron steps once
and then again that black Bishop will be
kicked home and uh White is ahead in
development remember white is the first
two have castled so Magnus may be facing
some early questions
and uh
I don't know if I should confess this
but I once had a conversation with
Magnus on a train and I was like oh my
openings are so bad I have nothing
against 1d4 and he was like just wing it
just play this setup and just freestyle
and he was like oh you can't really go
that wrong so he's actually putting his
money where his mouth is and he's uh
he's following his own advice playing
this opening setup is black yeah I I
kind of again I would nearly agree with
that statement I would say you can't
nearly go wrong but you have to have an
answer to the Breakthrough that white
the whites break through which would be
E34 if you have an answer to that then
you're good and there you see Magnus
actually didn't develop his Bishop to
squares forward he went all the way to
B4 and the whole idea is that yes it
kind of takes advantage of a great
Square that's now become available but
also it prevents white from breaking out
in the Santa with his desired E3 E4
break yeah maybe we can show this Pawn
break because that will be a theme quite
likely of the
of the upcoming middle game so here
black has just planted his Bishop on a
nice Outpost if he hadn't if he'd chosen
maybe a more logical square or a more
traditional square at least one of these
two as you mentioned Ivanka than white
May for example move the queen like May
castle and uh now this is the key break
uh opening up the center opening up this
bishop to come to a very active square
and if we do for example see a bunch of
exchanges in the middle of the board
then you can actually Reach This Pawn
structure from a lot of different
openings but white is supposed to have a
small Advantage because these two
control a lot of space black is a bit
cramped
a solid but yeah it's harder to break
out so by planting his Bishop on this
Square as he has done Magnus he's made
it incredibly difficult for white to
play that E4 yeah break that you
mentioned Ivanka so uh okay mama jarov
knows that if he ever tries to push this
Pawn the Knight might be captured so he
gives it some extra protection
Max Bishop undefended as well so you've
got to watch out for some tactics along
this diagonal uh if the bishop is no
longer
um defended yeah I mean I would be
tempted to just move my queen now to
protect it for example
that would be a good advice as well
because otherwise like you said he did
that night text Pawn is in the uh Knight
takes porn the whole idea is yes you
give up your night but if it's captured
then Black's Bishop will fall and
another key detail is that if the black
Bishop captures White's Bishop this
Knight is in time to save itself with an
in-between move a check first of all and
when the Knight is captured white
regains the bishop and has won a pawn in
the process but Magnus okay he's
continuing to surprise me at least uh
every single move in this position he
simply captured a pawn and after it was
recaptured he castled he's getting ready
to break out temporarily white has more
space in the center white has a small
Advantage there but no time again to
push because if you push then the Knight
will be captured and the pawn in the
middle will no longer uh be supported
wow this is I'm learning I must say this
is something I've never really seen
before what Magnus is doing and uh it
looks like he's got a very healthy
position if white can't push in the
center for example if white has to move
then black breaks
this bishop suddenly is a free piece
it's looking down at a great diagonal
that's the kind of MVP in these
positions if you get that Bishop
liberated is the most amazing thing in
the world in return black can't sorry
white can't really stop that pawn break
say they have to take precautions they
have to actually and just prepare for
this opening and move the queen to the
Santa move the Rook to the center and
start asking black what are you gonna do
about your queen where are you gonna put
it but um where are you going to place
that is what I wanted to say yeah and uh
still very tense battle I I have to say
I don't think black is like 100 equal I
think white still has like something
that we call a niggle
but it's very very slight and it could
just evaporate within the next few moves
that's the thing for example if we do
see the white Rook move across okay he
has chosen this queen move but I'm
assuming Magnus will break out by
pushing his Pawn there we go we have
just seen that for example a situation
like this if we do see a Trader Pawns in
the center it's almost most in metrical
now in terms of structure and that's
where it could evaporate as you
mentioned Ivanka things could disappear
if all the pieces get traded off no way
to create any pawn breaks and it's just
very balanced so I'm expecting Magnus
maybe not to rush Magnus is known for
liking to keep the tension and I'm
expecting him maybe just to move his
Queen out the way
again that would be very logical almost
playing copycat doing what white did a
few moves ago you never want a queen
opposite a rook so uh yeah you want to
move her to safety
yeah very tense I yeah despite the fact
that there's still some life left in the
position I do feel Magnus he's survived
the worst and it's not necessarily a
manager of type of position Black's King
is super safe and manager of he's always
trained his eye to look at the
opponent's king he'll be frustrated with
the outcome of this opening oh
no direct attack no no direct attack but
still very interesting position brewing
and uh was the map uh Magnus is thinking
about what to play well we do have an
appreciation tweet from Han Solo who
actually earlier on played Magnus
because he was the first winner of the
nft and he says every chess fans wildest
dreams thank you Champs Chester for
making this happen keep building and I
hope to see you guys again in Singapore
for a rematch oh that would be so cool
that would be very cool tournament in
Singapore I know and have it in the bay
Towers I think it's good Arena
have you I stayed in that hotel one
night
it was incredible
um it's one it's on my bucket list I
have a few places in Asia that I would
love to go and Singapore is one of them
and uh whilst the players are also still
thinking we do have a picture of uh e
hang on let me just get the name
e-m-g-e mikolai
trying to solve the puzzle oh I want to
see Andy says uh I've got this one he's
not going to post the answer but again
he's going to repeat David's advice it's
ha it's way how you should try to solve
it you gotta think outside the box aha
see a lot of people suggesting checks
you don't necessarily have to capture a
piece aha it's a big hint
okay
keep those pictures coming as well we
want to see how you guys are working on
this super duper hard puzzle mate and
two yeah we like to play we should show
it again it's so difficult and uh let's
bring up that puzzle one more time and
if uh you have a phone for example near
you take a picture of it when it comes
up here on the screen
why to play mate and two it's such a
difficult puzzle but it's so much fun to
sit together and try to solve it yeah
like see a lot of people just uh saying
that they they spent 25 minutes trying
to solve it they were they abandoned
their quantum physics assignment okay we
have some smart people we do we do and I
can say they got that one right we have
a lot of people also confidently
suggesting checks and again you have to
think about all of Black's replies don't
just go for the most obvious and
remember mating two way to play and it's
a beautiful one yeah you need some
finesse you need some sophistication you
can't just do it by brute force uh
unfortunately in this puzzle it's not
the typical puzzle where it's like you
give a check follow up with an easy mate
this one you need to be very very sneaky
that's uh yeah well done to those of you
who have solved it already at home
without checking an engine is it
difficult to create these puzzles as
well do you have like people who are
experts on you know making crossword
puzzles also making chess puzzles yeah
we call them composers so this is an
endgame study you compose the study and
these various different types of
compositions there are specialized
people I mean I was recently reading on
Twitter and that a fellow Grandmaster
from Poland he entered the World Chess
problem solving uh Championship oh wow
he's won the title I think a few times
but uh even he struggles to solve some
of these uh different types of positions
and often it takes hours months days
just to come up with these ideas and it
can take just as long to solve them but
uh well one of one of my friends he
actually was a world champion in solving
problems and I asked him you know which
one is easier solving problems or
actually playing chess and I was
surprised by his answer he said actually
solving problems is easier because he
says you know there is an answer aha
that's true and once you've kind of
figured out certain solving patterns
things become a lot more standard but I
ingest anything goes you don't have any
help it's just you and your brain yeah
and just we're guessing half the time we
know that five or six different moves
will probably lead to an equal position
we just have to pick one and we have to
try and plan uh accordingly but yeah in
Puzzles at least you know okay it's
white to play and mating too you know
there is a win it might take you five
hours to solve but eventually you'll get
there
and uh yeah I'm hoping it doesn't take
the views at home that long though keep
studying those uh assignments don't let
us distract you too much again I do love
the honesty of our audience a few of
them are going oh God bless the engine
another one's like oh easy peasy
well if you're admitting to it yeah yeah
as long as you admit to it I think it's
uh wow it's okay it's okay but it takes
all the fun away don't use computers for
this yeah I mean just have a go have a
go at solving it you know involve all
your friends and uh it's a lot of fun
and go to have a nap on it this is also
something that I once did you know I
I had like a 10 minute nap and then I
was like ah this is the answer and then
I was like okay best feeling right yeah
it is it is kind of Eureka moment when
you solve a puzzle when you play a good
game as well you feel on top of the
world
yeah and meanwhile Mama jarov he's
playing very ambitiously it wasn't his
type of position I said but he's trying
to make it his type of position and he's
pushed forward in the center with the
pawn that requires some calculation it
is a temporary Pawn sacrifice but I
don't think Magnus should get tempted I
don't think you should capture uh this
Pawn in the center of the board and
let's show what Magnus is calculating
right now he's got 10 minutes and okay I
was gonna say he might be calculating
moves such as this one first thing you
look at might just push this Pawn
forward in the middle it is attacked
twice Defender twice but you can remove
a Defender so you can capture the Knight
on C3 white will take back and for
example you could jump forward win a
pawn with black knight attacking this
bishop as well but the downside is that
after an explosive Knight takes Pawn
capture blowing open the center
remember this line that we talked about
the black queen vulnerable and pawn
takes Knight this would be a deadly
check suddenly the black king is hit it
has to run to the corner and Rook takes
Knight white regains the material with
interest and uh here white is one
important but more importantly attacking
the queen attacking the bishop and
and this Pawn on G7 uh this would be
deadly so Magnus he didn't get tempted
to get greedy after the pawn push yet
instead he moved his Knight into the
center I was going to say if you want to
play it safe you could also move your
queen off that central line but Magnus
perhaps are worried about white stepping
even further forward with his Pawn he's
blockaded
couple of threats have appeared as well
Queen takes Knight for example
is one threat the Knight a bit loose in
the middle of the board
and also in some circumstances you can
take this bishop which is defended but
maybe that would be a favorable trade
for black
uh what do you think of this one Ivanka
Suddenly It's really heated up I thought
we'd see a slow maneuvering game but
it's getting tactical it definitely is
getting wild I mean with these two
players I think it was only a question
of when and like you say it's a very
complicated position especially when
you're in these positions where there
are no Pawns in the center everything is
very much on a move by move basis
everything is going to hinge on how you
develop the pieces how you activate them
whether you give them a role whether you
can post problems for your opponent and
at the minute it is Magnus saying to
Shaq how are you going to defend your
night
how are you also going to preserve your
light squared Bishop yeah
I've got to admit this is one weakness
that I feel I have in my game when it's
purely about piece play when I prefer it
when there's some porn structure
questions when there's some porn breaks
to play for long term when it's purely
just okay I have to move my wow okay my
major off gives up a piece but there is
a trap involved I think this is okay uh
wow what a move that is so creative but
yeah when it's just about pieces you
have to just calculate you have to work
out every single option we have to jump
back in because is it okay this move
made us both lean forward in shock we
were talking about how this Knight is
attacked you have to defend it I have to
move it man Majora said no I don't care
I'm just going to retreat my bishop and
Magnus doesn't take the bait he moves
his Queen away if the queen had come to
capture this White Knight and the white
Bishop just moves and the queen is
trapped in the center of the board
wow this is really beautiful I mean it
looks like the queen should have some
Escape Route but no she's attacked twice
as well a double attack
and uh there's no way out for her every
Square she wants to run to is covered by
one of White's minor pieces
so um yeah what a trap that is not
obvious at all it did cost manager for a
couple of minutes though uh retreating
to the square with his bishop and Magnus
said okay I know you spent a couple of
minutes playing this really clever trick
I'm not gonna fall into it I'm gonna
move my queen to safety
and this has however given a lot of time
to push his Pawn so now this wall of
Pawns blocks out the effect of Black's
light squared Bishop this is quite a
nice formation uh against this piece and
um just before there was any problem
with the White Knight
has blocked unplugged this diagonal with
White's Bishop it's still a bit loose
I've got to say for Mama graph but if
you can solve the issue of his knight uh
the issue the tension at least along
this diagonal then white should have a
small advantage
due to a Superior Pawn structure yeah um
but there's a lot of tension with that
Knight and it does feel like Magnus has
a sacrifice Brewing
yeah I can't see it just yet but I'm
thinking of jumping the Knight to some
strange square but it doesn't quite work
unfortunately
yeah maybe I mean my majority with this
last move he's getting ready to double
up his two Rooks he's going to put them
both on the default maybe Magnus should
play copycat maybe he should do the same
for example the black rook in the corner
is the only piece that's not really
joining the action yet but you can move
your Rook up the board and maximum
tension here I mean look at all the
Rooks
pinned against this Knight all the other
Rooks uh all of White's Rooks just tied
down defending this Knight
if I were that night I would want to run
away hop away as soon as possible yeah
because it's just so uncomfortable uh
this Central tension I I really like
that plan I think that's like the one
that you play without thinking is it
possible to also take use of the dark
squares and move the Knight to the edge
of the board with the idea of hopping in
to the F4 Square yeah maybe hopping in
here later for example if white plays
too slowly if white moves the king you
could no maybe not right now but uh
let's say white I don't know who's the
bishop now you could hop into this
Square uh because after Bishop takes
Knight The White Knight would no longer
be defended
so this would be one clever idea
potentially that looks very tempting as
well that would be maybe a magnet way of
doing it but first he improves his
remaining pieces I'm just laughing
because computers like top suggestion
move the Rook closely followed by second
suggestion or moving the Knight to the
edge of the board so we're both right it
doesn't matter taste exactly and that's
the thing in these middle games is still
maximum tension all the pieces on the
board and it is a matter of taste it's
this is where the players can kind of
put their real stamp on the game and uh
Magnus is trying to put a stamp on by
playing positionally improving all his
pieces Mama jar is still unable so far
to get that activity that he's really
craving right now especially down in the
match
yeah it's all about the defile all about
this Central File with the Rooks lined
up against each other staring off
and uh yeah yeah I'm the clock times at
least this time manager of he's not too
far behind unlike game one yeah he'll be
happier that's uh yeah all to play for
bar slightly over two Magnus Carlson's
side he is up by one point after winning
game four
in the other games
I think Ashley Barr is well it shifted
now in the game between Argentina Garcia
and Wesley so roughly in the middle
maybe slightly over to Wesley Soul's
side in the middle between giri and Duda
it was Duda who won the first game there
and it is definitely over to pragside in
game two against so maybe Prague just
like yesterday is winning the first two
games
but yesterday it collapsed for him he
did lose the match eventually even if he
won the first two games
is it
we do have four players on site in San
Francisco in the U.S and uh Tanya is
also there together with I mean there's
a bunch of guests there every day Tanya
and uh
who's uh in San Francisco with you right
now
I've got a player with me a very special
player she's
is the youngest in the world to ever
beat a grand master she did that when
she was just 10 years old not just that
she's one of the top Junior players in
the country it's Carissa Karissa welcome
hi thanks for having me we're so excited
to have you here with us and we see you
here with a bunch of friends I want to
ask you that okay
the youngest Grandmaster from here
you're a player who beat a Grandmaster
when you were all of 10. the chest fever
is on in the United States
oh yeah for sure I feel like it's kind
of a result of Queen's Gambit but that's
already been said a time time so
you mentioned Queen's Gambit but you
also think that over the last couple of
years with streaming and just becoming
this esport that's helped as well
oh yeah for sure I wouldn't say I
followed along super closely with chess
online so I can't say too much on that I
would say like Esports
um like the Champions chess tour
everything like that has been doing a
lot for chess so have you been following
the tour closely
honestly I haven't been following super
closely I'm gonna be really honest with
you
um I've mostly been focusing on school
and stuff
you you mentioned about school and
you're studying at Stanford what's that
like being a top Junior player and
having to manage a college
um yeah I guess like this first quarter
I haven't really been doing a lot of
Chess so the US championships happened
recently and I skipped out on that just
so I could sort of figure out like a
balance between my chess and college
life before I get back into it
but they're all your friends here
they're all strong players what's the
chess scene like in college to play uh
in college teams
um yeah we have a chess club it's kind
of vibrant but we're gonna play pan AMS
and uh maybe a few other team
tournaments throughout the year
you mentioned you haven't been following
the tour so closely but Wesley was one
of the top performers in the Champions
chess store the last year and he is uh
making his debut for this year this time
in the finals are you rooting for him oh
yeah for sure Wesley and I
um met what we played like on the same
team at Olympia and he's a great guy so
it's definitely my favorite here to win
the Olympiad still has some rough
memories for me Carissa but I have to
ask you it's always amazing to see the
US theme and the youngsters there
because it feels like there's a really
healthy competition and a really good
relationship amongst all of you you guys
seem like you're great friends oh yeah
for sure I would say I'm like very close
with
um everyone on the U.S team the I know
the community's just really strong we do
like a lot of team bonding so I think
that really helps especially for
performance at the at the Olympiad
and what about speed chess that's
something that I know the U.S players
love uh having Hikaru here as well one
of the best speed chess players Wesley
who just won the global Chess
Championship uh how's that and do you
also enjoy rapid and Blitz oh yeah I'm
definitely a fan of rapid and Blitz I
can't say I'm very good at it though but
uh something I like to do in my free
time
awesome well enjoy the games here today
and we're really glad you could join us
thanks thank you
how cool to hear from uh Carissa Yip an
international Master 19 years old now
focusing maybe more on her studies at
Stanford but it must be so cool to be a
part of American chess with high school
teams and college and university teams
and just the team spirit that they're so
good at in the US yeah definitely and
also the the US team had such great team
spirit I know the female team this is
maybe probably the open team as well but
uh yeah they're a great bunch of women
and uh they're very ambitious and also a
great great spirit and uh she's at
Stanford as well has such good chess
pedigree Daniel noraditski was there
Alexander botes also studied there you
know it's just a fantastic place to be
wow and the future must be super bright
for American chess both for the women
and for the male players youngest
Grandmaster ever Mishra is an American
yeah I'm mean we talk about India quite
a lot now we talk about Uzbekistan after
they won the Olympiad but the US I mean
they've got such strength and depth and
especially the last few years there's
more and more support for the young
players financially and a lot more
playing chess professionally which is
really nice to see there's always been
plenty of talented players over there in
the US but
um now more and more through streaming
through playing they're kind of making
chess their lives and yeah I think that
does start at school it does start with
that kind of team atmosphere I'm a bit
jealous of that I wish we had that in
the UK in other parts of Europe
um it really does lack there but uh yeah
in the US I mean Chris is just one of
many many talented young uh young
players in the US
it's great to see yeah how cool my mind
was Carlson he is in the U.S he really
enjoys being in the U.S he travels there
quite a lot right now playing mom and
yarov with the black pieces and we've
mentioned a bunch of times it is with
the white pieces that it seems to be uh
going best for these two players against
each other but right now the bar is
definitely over to Magnus aside yeah it
feels like Magnus is outmaneuvered Shaq
somehow um it's still very tense very
unclear and I'm struggling to see the
Breakthrough for black I don't see any
immediate uh way to take advantage of
this tension in the center maybe Magnus
as well slightly frowning he'll sense
that he's doing quite well also just
while we were having that interview
manager have lost two Tempe he dropped
back white tonight in the center then he
planted it back in the center of the
board
um avoiding a trade of Rooks avoiding or
going for that simplification which
might have equalized position and it
feels like now is the moment for Magnus
to take advantage but how Ivanka yeah I
mean I I was thinking about this I mean
why does the bar love Black's position
so much and for me the move that kind of
keeps on jumping and is jumping out here
is just simply to put the Knight on the
edge of the board and try to control the
dark squares there's a lot of tension
around the squares of G3 F4 E3 and we
have to remember that is pin on the C5
G1 diagonal yeah I mean there's a lot of
targets there Black's Bishop could get
greedy at some point start munching on
all those pieces but yeah as you
mentioned Ivanka this move very tempting
bringing the Knight into a hole on the
G3 Square the computer we actually see
stockfish's suggestions in front of us
the computer Advocates not improving the
knights yet but first improving the
black bishop and bringing it to a nice
open diagonal cutting across it looks
like it's hitting thin air but it could
support potentially later a night jump
into D3 that could just break White's
coordination some tactics uh with that
maybe the computer also suggests just
stepping back with this Knight I think
it's similar along the lines of what you
were describing now your Vancouver just
dropping back with the Knight and later
on going in to the F4 square with the
other night perhaps
um the third move of the computer
however is the one that really jumps out
at me really shocks me because the
computer's third choice suggestion is
just dropping Black's Bishop into A8 and
that makes zero sense at all but it just
shows that black and waster move that
can do nothing with his bishop and still
maintain the advantage so that's how
dominant Magnus is right now that's how
much control black has over the position
due to the tension along the defile due
to the tension along this diagonal as
well both of it both of those lines are
very uncomfortable for white and it's
not easy to break out and Magnus he goes
for your move arguably the most tempting
most natural move in the position he
improves his Knight yeah he improves his
Knight I was going to say that moved the
bishop to the corner of the board just
ignoring that opponent up for grabs on
H4 and just go yeah I'm still much much
better I mean
exactly it would be so unnatural if
Magnus played it I would be like right
check him something is fishy research
yeah exactly let's scan him for outside
assistance yeah but uh he didn't play
that odd looking computer move instead
he brought his Knight to the edge and
again we see the computer suggestions
but look at this now the margin for
error it's a bit like game one of the
day Shaq has only one move to stay alive
and it is the most natural move in the
position but it is also very committal
White's best move is to just bite the
bullet say okay I don't want to be
pushed back any further I have to kick
you back and uh to kick back this Black
Knight the Knight Will Retreat I'm not
sure which direction it goes it can step
back this way or it can step back this
way and uh in either case at least now
white would have a chance maybe to push
forward to start playing against the
black king to start opening things up
this is Shaq style but two minutes left
on the clock he hasn't had his way today
it does look weakening so will he
hesitate will he miss the moment to push
this F Pawn forward everything else as
we see for example bringing White's
Knight to this nice Outpost shuffling
White's King into the corner that would
be bad that would be very strong for
black and okay Shaq does find it and
Magnus doesn't even hesitate between
this Choice he drops back to undermine
White's stronghold in the center he's
looking good for black Batman did find
the best defense
and now he has a variety of moves it's
all about this night in the center he
has to move it and the computer reflects
that either you drop back this way maybe
a bit unnatural looks like you're going
the wrong direction away from your king
or the other top two moves uh maybe the
most natural capturing a set of knights
trading pieces off the board or stepping
back towards the white king with the
Knight
what do you think you'll play Ivanka I
think he's actually going to retreat the
knight uh this last move moving it to F3
attacking a pawn because I have to say
the position despite all appearances I
think it's still incredibly unpleasant
for white I mean even if you trade off
all the pieces black sir pieces are just
so great I mean they have has pressure
on the dark squares the F4 Pawn is weak
and to me this is a fantastic position I
would be very positive about winning it
if I were playing on the dark side but
then again
on the dark side on the dark side yeah
no
yeah and uh I agree Ivanka even this
position that we're showing on the
analysis board even if all the Rooks
come off it's still domination for black
for example the dark squared Bishop of
this tension if you trade those off as
well Magnus remember he's an endgame
Master but he would be happy to trade
off the queens and it's all to do with
the one weakness it's just this F4 Pawn
there's no way to defend it uh no good
way at least because the Knight is
attacking you can't step forward you
can't defend with a pawn you have to
drop back with your knight but then
suddenly this Pawn on the edge of the
board drops off and yes this is seven
moves down the line six seven moves down
the line but every move would be a
capture every move would be forced if uh
manager starts by trading Knights and he
doesn't trade enough Knights that
variation would have begun with Knight
takes Knight he does find the computer's
best move but he is heading in the wrong
direction with his Knight and now look
at this poor piece this poor Bishop on
the edge of the board it's a block of
wood right now it needs a few moves to
get back into the game yeah and I was
also super concerning is that the
position is still sharp still lots of
tactical possibilities
and Shaq has a just over 30 seconds on
the clothes
oh it's getting tough yeah and I
remember game one not only did he make
mistakes when low on time but he didn't
even try to defend so he was worse in
that end game he was probably losing but
he just resigned he just gave up because
he feels really uncomfortable Shaq
especially when Magnus has so much time
to maneuver with and to cook up these
dangerous ideas
I think we'll see a few exchanges I
think we might see something similar to
that line that we just showed with
Brooks coming off the board Bishops
coming off the board it's just about
whether Magnus can start to attack some
weaknesses in the white Camp white king
is the weaker of the two as well
remember and that's not a situation that
mamajarov is used to he doesn't like his
King being the target struggling today
Mom Daryl but what can you say about
Magnus Carlsen today is this uh just him
really on fire so far so good for Magnus
yeah it feels like day one he won
against Wesley so but it was a bit shaky
day two he control things against Eric I
see one or two small slips but today
no mistake so far from Magnus not even a
small in accuracy yet he's outplayed my
major off with black no mean feat no
easy achievement
it seems to me like it's a very smart
opening Choice he seems to have gauged
how a mama jarov plays he seems to have
understood the weaknesses and the
strands and he's just chosen very good
openings
the set of Rooks have left the board
I'm expecting a second set to also
disappear in the next move or two me too
I'm also expecting a black knight to
spring forward to the B4 Square
it's very difficult to come up with an
attacking plan for Mama jarov I mean
there is one hope and that is the queen
is attacking the B6 Pawn Yeah White's
Queen does have some targets I promise
White's Queen is also required in the
defense exactly if she gets gradient
goes off to take some of Black's Queen
side pawns then uh there might be yeah
she might leave weaknesses behind Magnus
three and a half minutes
yeah I think taking a set of Rooks off
would make sense blacks and Knight as
you mentioned both the Black Knights
have nice outposts to come into and sit
on and if you look at the dark squares
actually a lot of black pawns especially
on the wings they're on dark squares and
white has no control over the squares
they cover uh White's light squared
Bishop is far from uh happy and the dark
Squad Bishops have disappeared so on the
dark squares black I think that's where
he wants to make his uh invasion
yeah uh yeah okay my major of waiting
for magnus's move what do you think yeah
I was just thinking ironically enough
some of the best moves in the position
would be actually retreating White's
pawns who stepped back with the April
and step back with the f porn then the
position would actually be completely
level especially the white F Pawn you
want it back on F2 protecting White's
King
yeah I agree actually if anyone white
would be better if White's pawns could
Retreat somehow but pawns can never
Retreat and okay blacks Queen slides
across so Dual Purpose move firstly
black defense all the pawns over there
on the Left Flank but also look at that
F4 Pawn black on the diagonal blacks
Queen adding pressure
that's a nice sneaky move as well
especially when your opponent's in time
trouble you want to set little traps
little threats and the more you create
threats move by move the more likely it
is that they will
walk into something nasty and okay Mama
jarov now this is true Mama jarov he's
trying rather than defend passively
which a lot of us would have done he's
trying to open up lines and indirectly
if there's a trade of Pawns on this F5
Square white slight squared Bishop
Suddenly It's on the same diagonal as
Black's King it might open up
it's a great move it's asking Magnus a
question how is he going to defend it
and he does actually trade off Pawns
um perhaps he was forced but uh it does
feel like this is playing into
mamajaro's plans yeah White's night for
example uh has access to this beautiful
outpost on D5 I don't think you want to
jump in right now I'm not sure uh
whether you can maybe you just have to
take the time out to go and recapture a
pawn jackets down to 13 seconds that
might be the key factor in the position
why is he not capturing the form is he
afraid of okay finally he he plays it 19
seconds left on the clock I expected it
to be instantaneous what could it be
have been thinking about if you know I
think he's just not in the flow yet Mama
jar of today he's just started a bit
tentatively just negatively just too
slow not trusting his instincts he
should trust his instincts he's beaten
Magnus a few times this season already
he is capable yeah that's the type of
move it's automatic you play it in one
second you build that time up for later
but it took him a while and Magnus now
I'm expecting
maybe that trade of Rooks finally to
happen that tension is almost unbearable
now and also Black's night to jump away
from blocking Black's Bishop on that
Left Flank yeah just improve the Black
Knights I think that's the key that is
definitely the key I mean something that
I would be attracted to is actually
springing that Knight to the B4 Square
just liberating the light squared bishop
and uh then putting pressure on White's
G2 Pawn yeah let's just quickly show
this black has a variety of very
tempting moves and the most natural I
agree Ivanka is probably the strongest
as well bringing the Knight targeting
this bishop and uh more importantly
opening up this diagonal
I mean you're forcing this bishop back
to a terrible Square back on B1 and okay
he does eventually play that and in my
major he just has to move quickly
nearly under 10 seconds you just have to
retreat your Bishop it's a bad piece
it's an automatic there's no other
option really you have to play it sooner
or later four seconds three seconds
that's fine and then he drops back his
Bishop okay okay but I don't know if
that trade of Rooks uh was the right
moment
it feels like the other Black Knight is
going to come in once the Black Knight
comes in suddenly the white king is
almost caught in a mating net if the
black queen ever Creeps in on the first
rank that's going to be Checkmate it
can't right now D1 is covered by the
White Knight but if the black queen can
ever break through onto this line game
over so uh okay Magnus does come in with
a black knight
Majora has to play for tricks Black's
pieces are so so impressive all on
outposts
can he hold the fort with 10 seconds
manager off we're going to keep asking
ourselves that question he's trying to
counter-attack wow pushing his Pawn
forward this Pawn is poisoned uh if the
black queen takes this Pawn then the
White Queen gets to the eighth Rank and
actually the black king is trapped
okay that's a clever move it is a clever
move but at the same time it's it feels
like a very committal move because after
Pawn takes Pawn the white is gonna have
to throw some action and at the same
time can you do that and Magnus has the
time to calculate everything because
like you say both Kings now in Mortal
danger and he has captured the pawn and
I guess maybe Shaq is in his element
actually he he knows it's not about
moving the queen to the right side is
actually about introducing all the
pieces to the attack and he centralizes
the Knight yeah at least for Shack he
has for the first time in the game a
Target and that is the black king so yes
he's gone down a pawn but Black's
doubled f-pawns don't make a great
impression and the black king is a bit
more Airy than it was earlier in the
game so yeah despite the fact that he's
a pawn down I think this was the only
chance for him and uh you mentioned
being in his element I think at least
Magnus will start to have a little bit
of doubt in the back of his mind for the
first time yeah it has taked under the
minutes as well Magnus yes and okay he
improves The Black Queen so now there is
one Queen check White Queen can go to
the top of the board with the check but
the black king I think it's just safe to
move
and he's coming close to the 10 second
Mark oh he's riding his luck here
um I mean the big question for Shaq is
how is he going to stop the black king
from finding safety and he just throws
his Knight forward this Knight could be
traded off yeah that's nice to just go
back and recapture is Magnus maybe just
going to switch from trying to go for
the white king is he going to switch to
an end game now because he is a pawn up
remember
sure yeah I think that's just maybe the
safest strategy against manager before
before things start to turn too much in
White's favor get rid of this white
knight Knight's an F5 should not be
allowed to survive
so okay a nitrate and Magnus saying
let's get the Queens off Shack saying
nope you're a pawn up I can't allow that
Magnus Singh let's get the knights off
and uh that also makes sense Black's
Knight was no longer really threatening
anything
recentralizing it
you can kind of bully wipe because if
you imagine the queens and knights
coming off the board in terms of Pawn
structure black not just the pawn up but
black is winning because uh a lot of
white spawns are on light squares and
black has a light to go Bishop to Target
those
which are okay under 10 seconds under
five seconds now four seconds you have
to move the Knight
he trades off he does trade off the
pieces but his position starts becoming
very very shaky I mean he can barely
move his Queen is forced to defend the
E1 Square this is why he Retreats the
bishop but uh this is magnus's type of
position all he has to do is think about
defending the H4 pawn and if he doesn't
need to do that then he can just step
forward with the King yeah if Magnus can
get the Queens off as well the end game
is completely winning for black just the
extra Pawn will count
and yeah that perfect coordination of
blacks pawns on dark squares white
spawns on light squares it suits the
black Bishop more than its counterpart
I'm expecting Magnus yeah just to move
the queen maybe defend a pawn you can
maybe offer a queen exchange as well I
think this is what Magnus is calculating
the black queen coming to the G3 Square
trying to force the Queens off the board
that's either very good or it might lead
to an end game that Shaq can hold so
much so Magnus sorry he has to work that
out
now Magnus down to 15 seconds
Suddenly It's a Race Against Time he's
now down to 10 seconds I I predict that
he's simply going to defend the pawn
keep it simple and no he Retreats his
Bishop
stepping back with his Bishop I don't
know if Mama Jara can get greedy now
maybe he can White Queen had a choice
maybe it could have gone to capture a
porn but mama jorv just defends
everything
again Magnus he has to try and get the
Queens off I feel like that must be what
Black's best winning bet before White
Queen gets active five seconds again for
the world number one and now he goes for
the queen Exchange
maybe he has to allow it if you don't go
for the queen exchange then okay this is
a problem Black's Queen is getting
really grabbing some Pawns and uh well
now is the time for the White Queen to
get greedy and grab a pawn and check on
the board King goes to the corner but
there's Queen takes porn yeah Black's
Queen can just take White's Pawn on the
H3 Square
Pawn on G2 is pinned Magnus can win a
pawn for free he doesn't spot it he
could have repeated the position and won
a pawn in the process
Mutual blindness there is still winning
for black it's still good for black
because he has two pass pawns on the
queen side but he could have ended the
game there and then whoa
hey this is nerves now from both players
and understandably it's been a really
really dramatic topsy-turvy game and uh
Magnus now his Bishop's under attack
from the White Queen on the fourth rank
the black Bishop
one square
allowing some tracks that is uh yeah
playing with fire slightly White's only
chance to save this game is to give some
checks surely yeah and uh here they come
and now there's another check King has
to hide probably in the middle of the
board actually okay
a few times first that's what he's doing
Magnus and now he goes to the middle
good strategy
and uh Magnus he's gonna be relieved
that Black's Queen defense a very
important Pawn over there on B6 and at
some point either Black's queen or
Bishop will leap back to blocks and
tracks yeah as long as Black's King
height and dark squares it should be
safe totally safe and just look how well
centralized the queen on East E3 is I
mean she is in the perfect square King
is hiding on the F6 Square
if there's a check it can easily be
blocked
yep and it will be blocked I think we
will see that on the board in a moment
Mama jar of looking away heading hands
now
yeah puffing out his cheeks he knows
that this one is gone he's facing Magnus
anyone else in the world you probably
play on you've probably uh believe in
your chances but do we see another early
resignation and we do Mama jarov throws
in the towel for the second time today
he goes up by two points now Magnus
Carlsen winning now with the black
pieces surprisingly against chakrian
mama diara